this man my buddy my colleague from the
nfl media group ian rappaport how are
you rap sheet what's up sir
uh rich that conversation with prime was
ridiculous
that was at the super bowl in minnesota
that was at the super bowl in minnesota
so he's been asked he did not take up
his recommendations well
look the deal with prime the deal with
prime getting his hair back or is he the
minute that he he got his hair restored
um he called himself the comeback player
of the year and um and he looks great he
really does look great but his is free
you know i mean like he gets his for
nothing because he's prime just a
different story but you're rich eisen i
should look into that
i mean you're trying to tell me you
couldn't get a
some sort of a
you know hair deal or
a little uh what do they call it barter
type situation for a little rich eyes in
time like just i bet you could yeah i
guess i guess i would be a walking
billboard for that sort of thing get
this man some hair broccoli
brockman would be so upset
we're so upset with her we call her we
call archer and great erlacker's an
ingrate he left us on the field benedict
are locker he did you left us on the
battlefield you know this is what i
would feel like if mike garoppolo got
here i'd be like
and now and i'm not obviously a fellow
bald but i would still feel like a
little offended of course mike like how
did you do this to us you were a bald
guy no or you'd say to him you don't
belong in my club kick him out
everything you know what i mean like you
just can't do that all right uh anyway
we're a day before the nfl season begins
uh in tampa
and obviously four days before it begins
writ large for for for all
why is tj watts still in limbo right now
it is an extremely hard negotiation to
do and it's not saying anything about tj
watt as a player he is a awesome player
he really is like one of the best
players in the nfl i think
ben roethlisberger said it perfectly
today when he was like give him all the
money he wants he's one of the best
players totally agree
uh he also comes from a football family
i don't know if you've heard this or not
yes
he's got some brothers that not only
post a tag show
um but also which is actually a really
good show but also play football so he's
well versed in the jj watt contract
which
was a very long deal that
you know probably didn't hold up as
great as some of the other this he wants
to make sure that his deal is perfect
and the steelers don't do
full guarantees beyond year one they
just don't structure contracts that way
and that has been the fight
um
i i don't know if it's going to get done
i hope it does mike common has been
optimistic
to me if it doesn't get done then the
question is like is tj watts going to
play and i honestly don't know the
answer though well
why can't the steelers make an exception
for tj1
this has always sort of been my
not that i have a contract stance but if
i did yes this would be it it's like
teams have principles you know like we
don't negotiate a contract two years out
and then they do it for their
quarterback and you're like well he's
our quarterback i'm like yes but some
players who are not quarterbacks have
that kind of power julio jones in
atlanta had that kind of power they did
a contract two years out
i i to me
if you are the steelers and you're
trying to somehow someway get this mega
deal done
for ben roethlisberger or for i'm sorry
for tj watt making the exception for
watt makes sense
i i'm sure there was a bridge i'm sure
they could figure it out
i know that time has sort of been
so time has sort of been running out um
so we'll see if it gets done today we'll
see if it gets done saturday right
before the season i guess you both
happen well then then tomlin will have
to break his rule right that if no
practice no play but you got to put him
out there i mean this is the bills this
is this is what it's all about how how
do you think big ben's statement um
landed in the general managers and
owners offices today
i mean i think ben's been there for 20
years so when he says even though they
love big ben and all that like
i'm sure there's a little bit of an eye
roll like thank you ben thank you for
your input we appreciate your
your
salary cap expertise and your contract
advice you know i just
i'm sure they roll their eyes at it but
his point is
there's a good one like tj watt's not
gonna get all the money in the world
he's gonna get a lot of money so you
know what they're doing
is probably not as much as
i don't know i'm sure it's not as big as
they all think it is i'm sure something
can get done i just don't know if
something will get done ian rappaport
nfl network insider right here on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line on the
rich eisen show one day before kickoff
in tampa florida
what's going on with dak he seems
healthy he's full go exactly what you
told us a couple weeks ago there's no
there there at all like there's not
everything that was wrong with him what
was wrong with him what was wrong with
him
what can we know about that um
so basically what it was and i found out
a little more on this today so he was
like i don't know if he was in a
walk-through or early on in warm-ups but
at some point
he tried to throw it too hard which is
like you know if you're an old man like
me and like like you i started saying
you try to throw a ball like a real
person now like it strains your shoulder
to try to throw it until you're like
fully warmed up right this is like me on
the golf course i'm forever stretching
myself into oblivion right nice um dak
did not so he strained it a little bit
and it really was a nothing injury
but
you can re-injure it easily like the
actual injury isn't bad but the risk of
aggravating it is high so they were like
super super super cautious
kind of creating this big deal
so they got all the publicity
unfortunately but what they didn't do is
reactivate it so they're actually in a
really good place he seems fully healthy
i think he is going to play great
um i think the cowboys as a team are
going to be really really good um i'm
looking forward to seeing it tomorrow
night why do you think that's amazing
all right so why do you think the
cowboys are going to be really really
good
yeah their roster is
loaded
like
you know we're all sort of conditioned
because we've done this a long time to
think of the cowboys as like a big
splashy team splash signings big name
guys high priced
this is a deep
talented roster
of mostly homegrown guys
um and it is just
i just think it's really talented like
i know they're they're 53-man roster cut
decisions were extremely hard some were
easy
dallas's were extremely hard i know that
all the talent that they wasted on
defense last year
they are going to kind of be able to use
again this year because
they signed or they you know hired a
coach and dan quinn who can make use of
the talents they have
and kind of bring them back to the
system they had two years ago when they
were really good defense so
you know to me it really is like
snapping your fingers in there a lot
better like i think they're going to be
very good rap sheet ian rap report here
on the rich eisen show okay and i'm
going to give you um
a chance to think about this with a more
long-winded setup than normal okay so
i'm showing you my picture here okay but
uh there are so many big-time off-season
acquisitions free agents signings and
trades and draft drafted players
which one which transaction whether it's
a free agent signing
or a uh drafted player or an acquired
player by trade
your ears to the ground you talk to a
lot of people which one scares the rest
of the league the most
and has the team that acquired this
player by trade draft or
uh free agent uh signing
uh is is sitting in the cat bert see
because they know the rest of the league
is genuinely concerned about this player
joining their team
which wow there were so many there was
so so so many trades and
i mean it feels like it feels like the
whole offseason has been one endless
transaction um
so i don't think it's i don't know if
it's any fun because i don't have like a
go for it spicy one but to me the two
the two ones that are the most
intriguing have the possibility of being
like the most
sort of devastating
are two of the biggest you know the
stafford 2la deal
sounds like he has been great and not
only like you know stafford's really
talented so that's not i mean we've seen
thrill for years he's great but it
sounds like
he has expanded the offense just kind of
creatively what he can do
so
and i don't know
like i don't know if my eyeballs will be
able to know but they are really excited
in the building about
just
because he's so talented and because
he's seen so much
where he can take this often so i think
staffordshire the rams is a good one and
then if julio jones is healthy
he is going to make the titans extremely
hard to defend and i know they are not
like a perfect team
you know how well can they cover on the
back end would be a question and all
that right offensively they're going to
be extremely extremely tough to defend
because it's like the lord the vodka box
against derek henry
you
you know put two on aj brown you put you
on julio like what do you actually do um
so i think those two trades you know
nothing under the radar those were the
biggest trades of the offseason um
but i'm excited to see kind of where
those go are there are other gms and
coaches and whoever you speak to agents
saying
yeah i'm saying the same thing i mean
that's what i'm saying is like which
ones have gotten the attention of the
rest of the league are those the two
stafford to the rams i know like
obviously for instance san francisco and
shanahan that might have been plan a
for you know moving on from jimmy g as
opposed to drafting somebody and trading
a bunch of picks to get drafted
for a lot of people like there was real
i i still almost can't believe the
interest
that the lions had in him i mean i even
at the time kind of underestimated it
because you know it felt like
all right you know the two sides are
kind of agreeing to part ways and kind
of an older quarterback like a lot of
people are interested in staffing um i
mean that probably that probably is the
one that drew the most buzz the julio
trade
i think the from the defensive
coordinators that i've spoke with like
during my camp tour and all that
that's the one where like
they're they're like what are teams
gonna do like they really don't know
and before you joined our program ian
rappaport here on the rich eisen show
before you called in uh you tweeted
carson wentz's a go for the the cults
in week one ago yes he's gonna be a full
partition practice today
he has been trending this way
um and he has been awesome um i
i think the colts after the surgery were
a little surprised at how quick he came
along i think wentz
probably knew that he was going to be
fine and probably knew he was going to
be the starter even if none of us did
it's just amazing like
we spent at nfl network and at every
other place a long time talking about
the
jacob ethan v ellenger quarterback
battle yes sir um and you know are the
colts gonna trade for nick foles and all
the other stuff and i'm sure carson once
hated all of it
um because he probably thought that he
was gonna play week one and we didn't
and now he gets to be like yup told ya
um so i think he's going to be not i
think like he's going to be good to go
um
i don't know how they're going to be as
a team it's he you know hasn't practiced
a ton um but i believe he will be
starting what about quentin nelson
about
him you know i think he's going to be
starting he's not going to practice
today
it's just bizarre that two teammates
have like almost the same injury right
um
i mean it's really just weird um
i
i know if quentin nelson can possibly
get out there and will
i'm not as confident in him as i am in
carson i'll say it okay uh and then i'm
gonna give you an open-ended question
ian about uh what we're reading
uh and they're
on twitter obviously and i'm sure he's
not paying attention to it and our buddy
mayok but what is going out
in vegas what is happening with the
raiders in vegas with their roster and a
couple of third round picks not even
making it to the season it's just a lot
of weird
transactions that may or may not have
mike's fingerprints on them or gruden's
fingerprints are all over them and
obviously it's one team effort and watch
the raiders can go and compete for the
afc west title i mean who the heck knows
right they have a ton of talented
players on their roster the question is
how do they all mix and what does gruden
like and dislike it just seems
a lot of question marks in
vegas right yeah with all due respect to
our friend mayak like i'm i'm
i got a lot of questions i really do two
third round picks not even seeing the
field for one second like it happens you
miss on drastics usually you don't miss
that much but it happens
um
i would say you know they are still in
roster construction mode so having to
sign kj wright right before the season
having to trade for denzel perriman to
beef up the linebacker group like that's
not what you want
put credit to them for for recognizing
an issue and trying to solve it
they have dr their drafts have been a
struggle it has not been good um they've
hit on some guys but it has not been
good
and
when you when that happens you have to
basically on the fly keep building keep
building keep trading for guys keep
signing guys like i think they could be
okay
you know not they don't have a great
depth but
just overall first-line talent
they could be a playoff team so if they
stay healthy i think they can be fine
the problem i have
is the sort of race to assign blame
and you i think you described it really
well like nobody knows whose fault it is
so like is it may ox fall for the draft
is that gruden pressuring women to do
things like i don't
it's hard to know who did what and i
assume because they asked the gm that he
takes ultimate responsibility
but
are we to assume that gruden has never
said actually no we're taking this guy
right
he probably has
right so i there's i have a lot of
questions about vegas they still could
be a good team
but just the way they have been built
i say more questions than answers last
one for you ian rappaport before i send
you on into your day uh then of course
we'll chat on the kickoff show on nfl
network tomorrow a night um and then
game day morning on sunday as always um
the uh the conversation in the league
that you're hearing who has the best
roster best team going in is it tampa
because they kept everybody is it green
bay because rogers came back is it
kansas city despite the changes up front
who who is it which one do you got for
me on that front i i would say
it seems to be like when i just kind of
like pick people's brains like what do
you think
it seems to be either green bay or
kansas city which is perfect because the
bucks are literally the super bowl
champion so it should be them and they
return their entire roster and they're
still awesome
um it's just hard to argue against
two great quarters not that tom brady's
not in his prime but like mahomes really
is and rogers probably still is so it
seems to be a battle between the packers
and kansas city
um so i would say those
two and you know the fact that the
chiefs completely rebuilt their
offensive line and i think got a whole
lot better there
um
you know the packers are kind of they
should be probably the same
the chief should be better and that is
certainly a scary thing it sure is ian
thanks the time brother we'll chat again
tomorrow always appreciate you coming on
here truly absolutely always a pleasure
rich take care right back at you at rap
sheet ian rappaport
right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here